et
[Musique]
à partir de la lune où ils se sont
réfugiés les shadows claude s'apprête à
lancer leurs premières expéditions vers
la terre pour à les exterminer gégène
leur est grave
les cosmonautes shadoks s'avance vers
l'ère de lancement
[Musique]
ils sont armés rappelons le de leurs
puissants exterminateurs anti geiger les
shadoks notre maintenant prennent place
dans leurs combinaisons spatiales
mais vous allez dire puisque la terre et
la lune en ce ton là était à deux pas et
qu'en plus il y avait des échelles à
l'une pourquoi se déguiser en cosmonaute
pour descendre sur la terre à cela on
répondra d'abord qu'avec les shadoks
il ne faut pas chercher à comprendre on
répondra ensuite que les echets la lune
même pour descendre
cela n'aurait pas du tout été assez
rapide
quand il s'agit de descendre les
échelles les plus rapides sont
évidemment les échelles qui n'existe pas
et les shadoks note justement descendait
comme ça les combinaisons spatiales
shadow qui sont étudiées pour résister
au choc du départ au choc d'arrivée et
au terrible assauts de l'ennemi
gg
[Musique]
vous voyez ici la combinaison spatiale
individuelle munie de tout le confort
moderne va si la combinaison spatiale
familiale voici la combinaison spatiale
de course à long rayon d'action
voici enfin la combinaison spatiale
articulé qui permet dons circle est
l'ennemi déjà d'octobre sont lancés des
shadoks notes sont arrivés on va lancer
maintenant leur capsule cosmique
le module terrestre qui leur permettra
de se déplacer en toute sécurité à la
surface de la terre
c'est le fameux costume autobus
prudemment silencieusement les shadoks
notre avance dans leur co spots aux
bulls réussiront-ils à exterminer gégène
avec ça
[Musique]
et